هدف ضخم لا شك ان كان المنطاد التجسسيا
كما تقول واشنطن فلماذا اذا هذه الطريقه
الكلاسيكيه في التجسس كلاسيكيه بمعنى انها
تعود الى عام
1794 خلال معركه فلورس في حرب التحالف
الاول وحتى ان الولايات المتحده استهلكت
استخدامها خلال الحرب البارده تطورت
التكنولوجيا منذ عقود لتحل الاقمار
الصناعيه ما حل المناطيل صورا من الفضاء
ادق واقل خطوره فهل هناك ضروره للمنطاد
اضافه الى جميع الوسائل الحديثه للتجسس
وهواوي احداها بحسب اتهامات الولايات
المتحده للصين فان الاجابه في الحموله
المنطاد يزن اقل ويمكن ان يكون اصغر وارخص
واسهل في الاطلاق من الاقمار الصناعيه اذا
تعددت الطرق والحقيقه واحده الصين تغزو
الولايات المتحده على طريقتها خيالها
تجاوز الحدود في تجنيد ادواتها لاختراق
امريكا وقبل ازمه المنطاد او المعلن عن
على الاقل قبل هذه الواقعه كشفت الولايات
المتحده عن استثمارات زراعيه صينيه قربى
منشات عسكريه امريكيه استثمارات كانت سريه
في البدايه قبل ان يزاح الستار عن
تفاصيلها مثلا منذ اكثر من ثلاث سنوات
امتلكت الشركات الصينيه اراضنا بمساحه
شاسعه وتحديدا بمساحه تقدر ب 777 كيلومترا
مربعا واثقه تقريرا لقناه فوكس نيوز صدر
في يوليو من العام الماضي التقرير حينها
دقه ناقوس الخطر استنادا الى ان هذه
الاراضي تقع في اغلبها قرب منشات عسكريه
والشركات مرتبطه بالحكومه الصينيه مساحه
الاراضي التي تمتلكها صينيه زادت منذ هذه
الفتره وعندما نتحدث عن الهدف فهو طبعا
لاغراض التجسس كما يخشى مسؤولون امريكيون
ويحذرون دوما